[Music]  renting a car anytime soon won't prank  the bank like it did over the summer but  there's a chance that car rentals could  still get pricier rental car rates were  five six seven times what they normally  were during carpocalypse that's during  the pandemic when the rental car  companies decided with demand way down  they'd sell off their inventory and  float themselves but mahan came back  much sooner than expected creating that  mass shortage  there is a little bit of worry that if  you know demand comes back really really  fast like it did in may june and july of  2021 that we may see prices rise again  and that's because of supply chain  shortages  the chip shortages making it hard for  car manufacturers to make more cars car  rental agencies tend to buy cars in bulk  and cheaper and right now those car  manufacturers are not prioritizing those  lower price sales